hello
i'm alexander rose the executive
director here at long now
today i'm going to be joined by sean
carroll from caltech and santa fe
institute
who's a theoretical physicist who's been
really studying
the nature of time itself and the human
experience of time and really how we fit
in it and here at long now
we've been doing talks that kind of
relate to time in many ways but this is
the first time that we're doing it on
time
itself i'm very excited to have sean
here welcome
sean carroll thanks very much sandra
it's a great pleasure to be
talking about time the nature of time
what it means for all of us
at the long now foundation obviously
folks along now have been thinking very
carefully about time about the human
aspects of time about how to measure it
how to
think about it and that's my jam that's
what i'm very
very interested in doing you know time
is just so
important to who we are as human beings
right we feel like
time is passing around us or we're
flowing through time
the metaphors they go back and forth i'm
not sure whether we're moving through
time or time is moving around us
but either way time is just crucial to
what it means to be a person we plan for
the future we remember the past
some of us are so fascinated by the
nature of time that we become
professional physicists and we learn
about what time means from the
physicist's point of view
and we learn a lot like physicists
understand a great deal
about the nature of time but there's
something interesting
maybe a little scary that happens when
you learn about time from the
perspective of physicists you learn
equations
they tell you how physical systems
evolve but this idea
that time passes or the time flows or
that somehow we move through
time that central most obvious idea
about time in our everyday lives
disappears it's nowhere to be found in
the fundamental laws of physics but it's
clearly there
in our everyday lives and we think that
we're made of things that follow the
fundamental laws of physics so what is
going on that's what i want to talk
about with you
today how to reconcile how physicists
think about time with how we experience
it in our everyday lives
and what that reconciliation teaches us
for what time means and what it means to
be a person
so let me start by explaining what i
mean when i say that this
passage of time notion disappears when
you learn about time from the physicist
point of view
what does a physicist do what's a
typical physicist kind of problem
to contemplate okay well think about the
planets
in the solar system moving around the
sun this is the kind of thing that
physicists are really good at
paradigmatic kepler galileo newton those
people
you're given the state of some physical
system by which
in this case we mean the positions of
all the planets where they're located in
space
and how they're moving right the
velocity at just one moment of time you
don't need to be given the history of
the planets
at one moment of time you're given where
they are
and how they're moving right now and
then you have
a recipe you have the laws of physics
you have newton's laws of motion
and newton's law of gravitation and from
those
you can predict the future from the
present state of the system you can tell
where it's going to be next you can
predict eclipses in the future
you can say where the planets are going
to be you can make an almanac okay
but there's something extra that is very
very important you can
also predict the past or retrodict if
you prefer
given the current state of the system
the laws of physics tell you
exactly what was going on in the entire
past history of the system
and real astronomers actually do this
they extrapolate the current state of
the solar system
millions or billions of years into the
past and the future
so buried underneath that little
discussion
is an idea that we call conservation of
information
all of the information you need about
the system right now its positions its
velocities and so forth
suffices to predict the entire future
and past
of the system if i told you exactly the
state of the system
a million years ago you could predict
what it would be doing
right now this is the disappearance of
this idea that time is flowing
time to a physicist ever since isaac
newton
it becomes kind of a label there's this
moment there's the past moment there's
the future moment
there's nothing special about what we
call now or the present moment
the laws of physics describe every
moment of time
as being on an equal footing and the
information contained in every moment of
time
persists into the past and the future
that's very different from what we're
used to in our everyday lives just as
one simple example
imagine you come across there's a glass
of water on the table it's a
slightly cool glass of water okay and
you ask yourself well
what was the state of that glass of
water a few minutes ago
maybe it was just a cool glass of water
just sitting there but maybe
it was a glass of room temperature water
with some ice cubes in it and maybe
those ice cubes
melted and cooled off the water the
point is
just given the macroscopic observable
information about the world
you can't say where it came from
unlike the perfect information we have
for the solar system in the real world
where we see the glass of water and we
can see a little bit about it right it's
temperature whether there's ice in it or
not
but we're not looking at every atom or
molecule of water
then suddenly information is no longer
conserved
there's information that used to be
there in the system did it have an ice
cube in it or not
and that's disappeared over time we have
an
irreversible process so what we're
seeing in the macroscopic world
is what scientists and philosophers call
the arrow of time
the difference between the past and the
future in particular
the asymmetry that we have when we think
about
now versus the past versus the future
and that asymmetry that arrow of time is
not there in the fundamental laws of
physics we have to dig in
a little bit to understand where it
comes from so let me just explain
how that asymmetry between past and
future shows up
in our everyday lives one aspect is that
there is an asymmetry of knowledge
okay in a very real sense you can
predict the future
but you're never really sure what's
going to happen right you know sometimes
our predictions come out wrong
whereas when it comes to the past we can
have records
we can have memories there are things
that exist
in the universe right now which we're
very very confident
tell us something specific about an
event that happened in the past whether
it's a photograph
or a book or a fossil a bone underneath
the earth
these are artifacts right now that
represent something definite about the
past we don't have
photographs or artifacts that tell us
about the future in the same way
but there's another asymmetry not just
knowledge between past and future
there's an asymmetry of
influence between the past and future we
have in our minds the idea the past is
settled
right it happened there's nothing you
can do about it whereas
toward the future we can make choices
we can do things now that affect
the future if you lift your left hand
versus lifting your right hand
that might have an impact on the future
but nobody thinks
that by doing something right now you
can influence
the past where did these asymmetries
come from
why is it that we can know more about
the past but we can influence the future
in some way
again it's nowhere in newton's laws of
motion
okay nor in any update of newton's laws
of motion general relativity
electromagnetism schrodinger's equation
in quantum mechanics
all of these attempts at finding a
fundamental laws of physics
have the feature that they treat the
past
present and future equally now i'm not
going to hold you in suspense too much i
actually
know the answer to this question why is
the past present and future
so different to us the answer is
something called entropy
and the second law of thermodynamics i'm
sure you've heard about this
before entropy is basically roughly not
exactly but close enough
the disorderliness of a system the
randomness the disorganization
and there is a law of nature that is
true in our macroscopic everyday world
that says that entropy increases over
time so a typical example
might be an egg you can have an unbroken
egg it's easy enough
to break the egg to scramble the egg and
in that process
from unbroken to broken to scrambled the
entropy of the egg increases you're
mixing things up you're making them more
random and that would just happen very
easily and naturally in the world
whereas
if you saw a movie of scrambled eggs
reforming into an unbroken egg
you would know right away someone was
playing the movie
backwards in time there's a
directionality to the evolution of these
systems
so the first law of thermodynamics just
says energy is constant that's good
the second law says that entropy
increases over time in a closed
isolated system or in the universe as a
whole you can clean up your room don't
get me wrong
you can lower the entropy in a localized
system by influencing it from the
outside world
but overall in the universe as a whole
entropy
increases over time so unlike newton's
laws or other attempts at fundamental
laws of physics
the second law of thermodynamics does
tell the difference between the past
present and future it says that entropy
will be higher in the future it was
lower in the past good that's nice
that's an explanation of something but
we want to do better why is it the case
why does entropy go up over time so this
was
roughly speaking solved in the 1870s by
ludwig boltzmann an austrian physicist
and some of his friends
what they did was they said entropy is
not just a rough idea
it's a highly precise quantitative
concept that we can attach equations to
that's what physicists like to do with
their lives attach equations to things
you thought you understood
so entropy in boltzmann formulation is
just look
when you look at a system a macroscopic
thing a glass of water with an ice cube
in it or cream and coffee or an egg
you don't see every little bit of that
system you don't see the molecules you
don't see the atoms of which it is made
so let's take cream and coffee as a
classic example okay
if the cream and coffee are separate
from each other
there's a number of ways you could
imagine changing the positions of the
individual
molecules in the cream or molecules in
the coffee
so that macroscopically you wouldn't be
able to tell the difference
but if you started mixing them together
if you started taking the cream and
mixing into the coffee you would be able
to tell the difference so there's a
small number of rearrangements you could
imagine
whereas if it's all mixed up right if
all the cream and all the coffee are
mixed together
then there are a large number of ways
you can rearrange the atoms and
molecules
to make it look exactly the same so
boltzmann says
that's what entropy is entropy is a way
of counting
how many ways there are to rearrange the
fundamental constituents of a system
so that it macroscopically looks the
same to us
from that point of view it's not at all
surprising that entropy
goes up as a function of time it's
simply because there are
more ways to be high entropy than to be
low entropy
if you have a medium entropy system and
just let it go
let it do its thing let it evolve into
the universe
it will naturally increase in entropy
since there are so many more
configurations that look that way
that part is easy the hard part is
if you have a medium entropy system why
was it lower entropy in the past
if it started lower entropy you can
explain why but
you seem to need a new principle to
explain that and indeed
that is exactly true think of the arrow
of time
this way there's no arrow of space right
if you were an astronaut floating out
there in space there'd be no difference
between up down left right forward
backward
but you know if you're here on earth
there's an arrow of space you can tell
the difference between up and down
nobody thinks that arrow of space is
deeply ingrained in the fundamental
nature of reality
it's just because you're in the vicinity
of an influential
object the earth the same story
is true for the arrow of time the arrow
of time according to modern physics
is not built into the fundamental nature
of reality
we experience it because we live in the
aftermath
of an influential event the big bang
14 billion years ago for reasons that
cosmologists
do not understand the big bang was very
low entropy the early universe was very
orderly compared to what it could have
been now
why is that true good question very
active research question
at the frontiers of modern cosmology but
for our purposes today
we don't know why but it's true the big
bang had a low entropy and once you say
that
it's clear that entropy is going to go
up it's been going up for the last 14
billion years it's going to continue to
go up
billions and billions of years into the
future
so good we think we know what entropy is
the number of ways you can rearrange a
system
we think it makes sense that entropy
increases over time
what we're left to do is understand what
this has to do
with our experience of time in the
everyday world
how does that help explain this
asymmetry we have about the past versus
the future
this feeling that we have that we're
flowing through time
well let's just take one example here's
my favorite example of an
asymmetry this is an asymmetry of
prediction
versus records you're walking down the
street you look down the sidewalk you
see a broken egg can we ask ourselves
because we're in a philosophical mood
what is the future of that egg likely to
hold
you don't know right there's many
different possible things that could
happen to the egg you could just sit
there
it could be cleaned up by somebody there
could be a rainstorm washing it away
there's many possible futures open but
if you ask yourself
what does the past of that egg probably
involve
with very high confidence you will
believe that there used to be an
unbroken egg
and it got dropped and it broke so right
away just seeing this thing
in the world right now this artifact
broken egg on the sidewalk
you infer a difference between the past
history of that egg and the future
history of that egg
why well it's not because of the
fundamental laws of physics
given the configuration today egg on the
ground
messy etc there are many many
arrangements
of the individual molecules that could
account for that
and accordingly there are many many
possible futures as we said many things
could happen
to the egg if all you knew
were the fundamental laws of physics
there is a precisely
equal number of past things that the egg
could have gone through
the conservation of information
convinces us that the number of
past possible histories of that egg is
exactly equal
to the number of future possible
histories of that egg
but there is one big difference that we
know the universe started with a big
bang
and that big bang had a very low entropy
this is what
philosophers call the past hypothesis of
low entropy
in the universe so we know two things we
know the current state of the egg
and we know the initial condition that
we started with very low entropy
we that's where the imbalance comes from
that's where we know
a little bit something more about the
past than about the future and we can
use that information
to say given the existence of a broken
egg on the sidewalk today
and the existence of a very very low
entropy big bang
we can infer that there used to be an
unbroken
egg as you go through your life as you
are remembering things and predicting
things about the future you are
constantly relying on the fact that the
entropy of the universe was very low
near the big bang
you might not have known that you are
relying on that fact but it's crucially
important
to how we live our lives that's the good
news we can say something
about where this asymmetry comes from
this asymmetry of
both knowledge and influence toward the
past and the future
but it raises kind of another worry that
we didn't have before
which is the following you know if all
that happens over the history of the
universe
is that disorder increases how did i get
here
i think of myself as relatively orderly
right the organs of my body the neurons
in my brain they're organized in kind of
a precise way
how could you tell me that something as
exquisitely organized as a living being
just came to exist out of increasing
entropy over time and of course you know
because i'm asking you this question
that i know what the answer is to this
at least i know a little bit this is
another
active research area but let's go back
to our favorite example of the cream
mixing into coffee it begins in a very
low entropy state
the cream and the coffee mix together it
ends up in a high entropy state
but that early low entropy state is very
simple right all the creams on the top
all the coffee's on the bottom
that final high entropy state is also
very simple everything's mixed together
it's
in between it's that intermediate state
on the journey from low entropy to high
entropy where
things look complicated where the cream
and the coffee are mixing together
in unpredictable ways forming little
swirls little fractal patterns that
would require a lot of information
to specify so that's the secret and we
have a lot to learn still to go about
this but basically
complexity naturally arises
on the journey from low entropy to high
entropy
this is a we think a fundamental feature
of how the universe works
that there's something about the journey
from a
simple beginning with very very low
entropy
to a simple ending with very very high
entropy
that can give rise to complexity so
entropy just goes up
but complexity first goes up and then
goes down
it's a temporary phenomenon which might
make you
pleased to understand what's going on
maybe a little worried
about the ephemeral nature of things
like that in the universe and indeed
this is not just a story about cream and
coffee
this is a story we can tell about the
universe as a whole
the big bang was about 14 billion years
ago and right after the big bang the
universe was very low
entropy also very simple it was hot
dense smooth rapidly expanding
that's all you need to know over time
what happens is the universe
expands and cools and structures begin
to form
gravity pulls things together and we can
see this we can take an
image of the background radiation from
the big bang from a few hundred thousand
years after the beginning
you can see the first faint traces of
structures forming
today 14 billion years later our
universe is
rich with structures there are planets
stars galaxies
people clusters voids it's a very lumpy
interesting
exciting kind of universe but that's
temporary
it's not going to last forever stars use
up their fuel they burn out they go dark
stars fall into black holes even black
holes don't last forever
in the 1970s stephen hawking taught us
black holes
radiate out into the universe and
eventually evaporate away
completely we think roughly speaking
that 10 to the 100 years from now
which is a long time even by long now
standards all the black holes in the
universe will have evaporated away
into almost nothing we think that the
universe is expanding and it's going to
keep expanding forever we don't know
that for sure remember predicting the
future is hard
but that's the best current theory we
have so the very far future of the
universe
is very high entropy but once again very
very
simple we for what it's worth live in
the exciting part
of the history of the universe and we
are part of that excitement
and maybe this is a story you're willing
to believe on general grounds complexity
comes and goes etc but
the leap from there to the specific
complexity of a living organism might be
a little bit hard to swallow right
you in fact you're taught sometimes i
wish you weren't but it's true
you're taught that living organisms are
somehow fighting against entropy they're
resisting entropy right
i think the opposite of that is true my
friend michael russell who's one of the
world's leading researchers
in the beginning of life the origin of
life here on earth once told me
the purpose of life is to hydrogenate
carbon dioxide
now that might not be the purpose of
your life but what he meant was
why did life start in the first place in
his theory and no one agrees
okay there's very large number of
different theories that are competing
right now but he has one of the
interesting ones
russell says there was an overabundance
of carbon dioxide
in the early earth and that was a low
entropy way
for those carbon atoms to be it would be
much higher entropy
for those carbon atoms to get rid of
their oxygen and take on hydrogen
convert into methane okay hydrogenate
the carbon dioxide
the problem was there's no simple way to
get
from there to here from carbon dioxide
to methane no simple reaction makes that
happen
what does make it happen is a complex
network of reactions
under exactly the right circumstances so
russell used this idea to make a
prediction
that underneath the oceans there should
be warm
hydrothermal vents of a very very
specific chemistry
and after he made that prediction it was
shown to be
true we found things like the lost city
formation
at the bottom of the atlantic ocean a
warm hydrothermal vent
which have exactly this complex chemical
structure
and russell's idea is that this network
of chemical reactions can get caught up
in a vessel a cell membrane
break away and form a precursor to life
here on earth now again we don't know
it's one theory but the point i'm trying
to make
is the existence of life is not
something that is a struggle against
the growth of entropy it is something
that is made possible
by the growth of entropy and once you
have that once you have these little
complex networks
that are using up the entropy around
them they can last for a long time
i want to emphasize this because this
goes into not just the origin of life
but what you are doing
right now the nature of us as bodies and
beings here in the world
roughly speaking you can think about
things that persist
okay configurations of matter that last
for a long time
there's two ways to be a persistent
object here in the world
one way is to be made of individual
pieces individual atoms and molecules
that are themselves more or less
stationary we might call this
microstasis the chair underneath you
right now
is made of a whole series of molecules
that are held together in a rigid
pattern
they're not doing anything they're not
going anywhere there's a solidity to it
which maintains over time
but there's another paradigm which we
might call homeostasis
where you have patterns that persist
over time
even that the individual pieces that
make up those patterns
are moving that sounds a lot more like
life to me right it's not just life
think about the great red spot on
jupiter this is a storm
okay this is a storm of swirling gases
in the atmosphere of jupiter that has
persisted for hundreds of years
it's not that there's one lump there
that is absolutely stationary
the pattern maintains over time
that's what you are that's what i am we
are patterns that get
maintained over time because there's a
lot of activity beneath the surface
you can try your best to be completely
stationary right you can still your
breathing
lower your heart rate enter a meditative
state but whether you notice it or not
at the cellular level there's a lot of
action going on a lot of atp molecules
are being created and used
atps are little batteries that fuel your
system
you can stay as still as you want but if
you plop your body
out there in the desert away from fuel
away from water and food and so forth
you will not last
for very long what we really do
is we maintain the persistence of the
patterns we call our body
by taking in fuel from the outside and
using that for maintenance for
homeostasis
why is that possible because entropy is
increasing
all of those processes that keep us
maintained
require an increase in entropy of the
universe
here on earth mostly that comes from the
sun
right we think to ourselves what does
the sun do for us as in terms of life
here on earth
the sun gives us energy you might be
tempted to say and that's true
but it's not the whole story the earth
radiates into space
just as much energy as it gets from the
sun the total amount of energy here on
earth is not really changing
that much the difference is for every
one
photon of light we get from the sun the
earth radiates
20 photons into outer space we get
visible light from the sun we radiate
infrared light out into space
so 20 photons of infrared with 1 20th of
the energy each
is what we do to the energy we get from
the sun
so in other words the sun gives us
energy
in a low entropy form one photon
we increase its entropy we do
photosynthesis we eat our food we think
we listen to talks
we make great speeches then we radiate
out into the universe the same energy we
got
but with a much higher entropy that's
what enables
all of the marvelous activity that
brings us to life
here on earth and that process is to
come back to where we started what
explains the idea
that we feel that time is passing around
us
that imbalance between past present and
future caused by the fact that
entropy is increasing so if you think
about it
you think about yourself right now at
the present moment you are in some
configuration right your body is doing
some particular thing and a day ago or a
second ago it was also
in some particular configuration a
second from now or a day from now it
will be in some particular configuration
but you don't know right you don't have
exact knowledge you have
vague knowledge of what your body's
doing right now you don't even have
perfect knowledge of that
you kind of have a memory of where it
was and you can predict where it will be
and let's think about that process not
the scale of days or years but of
seconds or
milliseconds okay the point is we are
constantly carrying with us in our minds
an image of our body and not just an
image of our body right now we have a
pretty good idea of what our bodies are
doing right now even though it's
imperfect right we don't have perfect
knowledge of anything
we also carry around where our body was
we carry the memory of what we were
doing just a tiny fraction of a second
ago
and we project into the future our our
brains are constantly doing this
they're making predictions about where
we will be where
our bodily configuration will be a
fraction of the second in the future
and they're constantly comparing its
prediction
as we made it to what we're perceiving
as where we are right now
and to what we think we were doing in
the past
it is that constant process of
comparison
past present and future on millisecond
time scales
that's what gives us the feeling that
time is passing
the feeling that we are moving through
time because there's an
imbalance we know a little bit more
about the past we make predictions about
the future
we constantly take in more data more
information
and we update and every single update
gives us the impression
that we are moving through time that's
not just us of course that's not just
human beings
every animal species does something like
this but we human beings do a little bit
more than the average
animal species we think about the future
in different ways okay every animal
species needs to react
to its present circumstance but you know
that human beings can react to a lot
more
than a fraction of a second right we can
think about the future we can
contemplate it we can plan
we can imagine different possible
futures
that is a very precious gift that took a
long time for evolution
to give us malcolm mciver who is a
neuroscientist at northwestern
university has a theory about this
his theory is that it comes back down to
the first
fish that climbed onto land okay you may
have heard of the fossil
tiktaalik which is probably one of the
first fish that climbed onto land
and mciver's idea is that when you're a
fish you can't
see that far in front of you even if
you're in very clear water the
attenuation length of light in water is
only a few meters you see
things in front of you but not very far
away so all of the evolutionary pressure
when you live in the water
is to see something and react to it
right away
is it friend is it faux is it food
whereas when you climb onto land
now you can see forever roughly speaking
right on a clear day there's no obstacle
to how far you can see
you can see things so far away it will
take you
time to interact with them in some way
and therefore
a new possibility opens up for evolution
to choose to develop in your brain which
is
the possibility to see something and
rather than just instantly react to it
think about the possible things you
could do
hypothesize different scenarios imagine
them
this idea is the birth of imagination
and in fact you can see how evolution
did this evolution uses
things over and over again and
neuroscientists have shown
that the part of your brain that lights
up when you're imagining a scene in the
future
is the same part of your brain that
lights up when you're remembering a
scene
from the past it's this ability
to imagine different future hypothetical
scenarios
that really has reached its apotheosis
in human beings we are better than this
at this than any other species of
animals and this is what really
makes us particularly human you could
talk about this in many different ways
here's an
example la sagrada familia this is a
cathedral
in barcelona and it was started
constructed
back in 1883 under the guidance of
antoni gaudi he took over from other
people who started it but gowdy designed
what he thought the cathedral should
look like it's an absolute masterwork
very very complicated a million
different moving parts and different
kinds of
styles and so forth and gowdy passed
away
in 1926 and the cathedral was nowhere
near finished when he passed away
and he knew perfectly well that it would
not be finished when he passed away
but he still wanted to do it even though
he knew it wouldn't be finished when he
died
what is going on what's going on is
gowdy could use his brain
to imagine what it would be like in that
future time when the cathedral was done
and it made him happy then the point is
not that gowdy thought that he would be
a ghostly
persistence over time that would be
looking down on the cathedral and
admiring it
he gained pleasure right at that moment
from the prospect
of the future and that's something that
we humans have the ability to do
the conditions of ourselves right now
depend out on our visions of the past
and the future
as well as our conditions here in the
present so
it all goes back to the cream mixing
into the coffee okay
entropy increasing over time that's the
story of the passage of time in the
universe
but it's that middle phase where the
cream is mixing into the coffee where
those little swirls
develop those swirls are us
that's what you and i are we are
temporary little bits
of complex structure in the universe
that are
part of the overall increase of entropy
over time that means we are ephemeral
we're not going to last forever that's
the bad news
okay we're not going to last for 10 to
the 10 to the 10 years we have a
lifespan we have an expiration date
but it also means we are interesting we
are
the interesting part of the universe
part of this complexity
is our ability to think about and model
ourselves and the rest of the universe
to do what psychologists call mental
time travel to imagine ourselves
not just in different places but at
different times it's that ability that
imagination
that flow through time that makes us
what we are as human beings
[Music]